you make you make a teepee for your
secret
that's it Connery you're on a timeout we
also getting over how amazing the SNL 40
year anniversary was no I guess that
makes sense since it was kind of a mixed
bag showcasing some great moments not so
good at all moments but the show may
have actually been incredibly
entertaining if you know the super juicy
history behind some significant moments
don't worry
I'm Gabe Hill writer I know all about
the juices and I'm gonna fill you in
this is hashtag news Chevy Chase was the
most important cast member of all time
at least according to check chase
seriously he's famous for being in love
with himself which explains this awkward
interview moment from the hour-long red
carpet interview before the show 1975
you were part of that past me what was
it like part of it part of it part of it
they left after one year and but I had
reasons to leave that attitude plus the
fact that he's been a jerk every time
he's hosted including a time when he
ridiculed a cast member for being gay
and when he slapped Cheri Oteri in the
back of the head true facts planes by
Chevy Chase was banned from hosting in
now with that knowledge doesn't that
make this super awkward introduction
from a not thrilled nor McDonald
incredibly entertaining three here
they're mere utility infielder
right now I'm going to introduce a man
right now what's it gonna at this rate
this moment ladies and gentlemen Chevy
Chase
Chevy wasn't the only cast member who
had to be given their entire own segment
to just stand there awkwardly and bask
in how great they are let's talk about
Eddie Murphy and he was the undenied
star of SNL in the early 80s but this is
also the only time in SNL history that
Lorne Michaels was not in charge of the
show
the show was so bad eddie murphy as buck
we decide these episodes are extremely
difficult to find anywhere and Lorne
Michaels and NBC liked to pretend they
never happened and you wonder why no one
remembers that Robert Downey jr. was on
SNL so for never getting credit for
basically carrying the show on his
shoulders for four years and then this
kind of mean joke in the 90s it's a
falling star make-a-wish kind of makes
sense why Eddie Murphy had refused to
come back to SNL for over 30 years and
why they had to give him his own segment
about what a great guy he is now with
that info you get why this speech is so
short and so painfully awkward I'm so
happy to be back here in a it's just
said I thought you guys were gonna write
there you guys were gonna do know a bit
of technical drama for you AV Club nerds
the audience was so packed with the 1%
the one-percenters that the camera crew
couldn't even move their equipment
around explaining all the botched
camerawork I'll take haurache for 200
for those of you that had heard rumors
that in sake would be reuniting for SNL
40 and then screaming into a pillow all
night when they didn't the secret reason
for it not happening JC sha said he
couldn't make it
damn you sha say he ruin in my life
here's a timely bit of drama for you the
face of NBC News himself Brian Williams
who's hosted the show and Camarillo
various times and who every one of the
cast loves was not invited by NBC Jim
Carrey knew some shenanigans were afoot
hence this question that clearly makes
everyone from the Today Show cringe
three hiding Brian Williams Biggie and
missing persons Victoria Jackson was
apparently there but the cameras managed
to never show her somehow
there's not really any drama there
except for the fact that she's become a
crazy mouthpiece for the
ultra-conservative branch of insanity
and literally uploaded a video yesterday
called Muslim in the White House I
wonder why they don't want to show her
much okay for those of you that noticed
the most famous of SNL's former writers
Conan O'Brien was mysteriously absent
from the night's proceedings I can't say
there's any drama here he's actually
taping his talk show in Cuba right now
Wow how Cuba the embargo gets lifted and
the first thing we send you is Conan
O'Brien I guess it's fair since you gave
us Chipotle they didn't give us Chipotle
oh oh let's quickly change the subject
Larry David co-creator of Seinfeld was a
writer on SNL in 1984 and after managing
to get only one sketch on the air the
entire year stormed out of the building
yelling that's it I quit but after a
weekend of regretting his decision he
went back into work pretending nothing
had happened and it actually worked for
a little while you still got fired at
the end of the season don't worry about
him though because here's him at SNL 40
pointing out to everyone what a terrible
mistake letting him go was and look how
big that way
we had like the biggest show which
basically translates to you idiots I'm
awesome
and finally last delicious tidbit of
Jarama SNL did a great tribute to all
the Weekend Update anchors over the
years and completely left out Cecily
strong who got fired from the job last
season but I mean that's not like anyone
remembers nine months ago that's it
that's like path to evolving
behind-the-scenes drama of SNL 40 hit
like if you learned a thing or two and
leave a comment if you noticed anything
weird that I did subscribe to hash tag
news for more insight on trending topics
and follow us on Twitter at new rock
stars I'm JP writer and I'm going to
Cuba then where am I going where tell me